Dave where is this Cavs team come from
where did this come from
I'm still wondering I basically asked
what brought that question after game
two I said you know you lost by thirty
some-odd points in the Indiana Game six
of that series
now we're less than a week removed from
that you've won three games in a row you
completely ripped the hearts out of the
Toronto Raptors how do you explain it
because LeBrons in the past had said
there is no such thing as taking
momentum from game to game and egos
obviously it that's just been what our
season it's that's how you encapsulate
it they've had some highs of course they
had that you know 15 game winning streak
before the trades that completely
reshaped their roster in February they
had some lows after that with the hand
injury to Kevin Love and it's obviously
the way they started off the playoffs
against the Indiana Pacers getting blown
out in Game one right now they have the
best player in the world and finally he
started to get some consistent help
around him yeah I know obviously it
helps for love to do what he did last
night and for what Tristan Thompson is
finally being able to string together
for the first time but III guess I need
to just repeat the question in a way and
because there's no answer to it I
honestly don't know how the Cavs have
been able to pull this off
based on everything that they have been
through all year long and is there is
there any point I guess during the
February remake the love return the
Tristan Thompson off court craziness
that that there is something that you
could point to that that was the genesis
of what we're seeing right now well one
thing I will say I ran into James Jones
who was on the last three final teams
for the Cavs he retired this offseason
now he's assistant general manager for
Phoenix Suns and the Cavs were in
Phoenix back in March and I was like I
don't know JJ like this this team I
don't know if they have what it takes
and he's like nope they're gonna be just
fine LeBron plays at a different level
in the playoffs
Terron lue is a playoff coach he makes
adjustments where he can you know kind
of dive into one team he takes over
the all the offense all the defense and
they're going to get rest in between
games you know no back-to-back and
they're gonna be just finally out of a
long run and you know one thing I don't
think JJ anticipated coming and I
certainly didn't was going into the
playoffs there's this big question mark
can they rely on guys like Larry Nance
Jr and Jordan Clarkson ever been up last
before I got like Rodney hood who had
only played one playoff series with Utah
before and completely fell flat on his
face compared to what his regular season
averages were for the Jazz and guess
what I Lou made it so they don't have to
rely all those guys whatsoever yeah you
know what I'm not even playing those
guys I go back to Tristan Thompson I'm
gonna go and give more minutes to JR
Smith in Kyle Korver rather than to
Jordan Clarkson and Rodney hood and it's
working and so I think what you do say
is that the veteran experience sometimes
that kind of cliched thing that you fall
on and just you maybe overvalue it but
it's paying off for this team and then I
think Tehran Lou who was certainly
taking his licks in the public cast fan
the media etc etc I think he's having a
pretty strong postseason well let's dive
into that Dave a little bit here because
amongst the trials and tribulations that
I reviewed leading up to my last
question I left out tyloo taking some
time off to I guess get some rest
essentially and your your fellow
syracuse honk and post Super Bowl 52
drinking buddy Chris broccoli loves to
point out that tyloo is is just a
figurehead that LeBron draws up the
plays and LeBrons the coach essentially
general manager don't forget to forget
that so what what is the real deal
assuming that brockman is full of it
well much like his boy tv12 the LeBron
of course will have input in what type
of plays that they run that a ridiculous
kind of claim to put that on any
reflection of the coach not having
enough foot spa to do his job or the the
superstar player overstepping his bounds
what ty has done is one he addressed his
health which
you know was necessary that was an
ongoing issue for the for the team and
for him personally all season he got
hired a new personal chef he's taking a
new medication really trying to exercise
more in put more time into sleep as we
also do but there is a level of trust
between him and those veterans and when
they had a doer died in Game seven he
said hey if we're gonna go out here and
of course had the Cavs lost in the first
round I mean there's major changes to
this Cavs team I could be fired LeBron
would probably be even more so have one
foot out the door all sorts of other
players on the roster could easy to be
traded or bought out etc they do a full
rebuild he said we're gonna go down I'm
gonna go down with the guys I want a
championship with we all experienced the
greatest moment of our professional
lives together
back in June 19th 2016 and it paid off
and that's kind of just being able to
read the room knowing your guys you know
obviously another thing we're going to
talk about off the court Tristan
Thompson going through that very public
indiscretions with his very public
girlfriend and and the mother of his
child
tyloo checked in on him and made sure
that he'd be okay and be able to give
him something and you know not all
coaches can Nestle handle that but if
you're a coach you played with Shaq and
Kobe and played with Michael Jordan and
Coach K G and Ray Allen and Paul Pierce
and coach Dwight Howard you kind of
understand what it's like to deal with
this outside personality and this kind
of superstar life that the Cavs players
have been living in the last couple of
years all right so let's look way over
the steering wheel here Dave you know
after Game six that that blowout
LeBron was asked if he's thinking in his
mind that this could be his last game in
a Cavs uniform in Game seven and he said
no I'm just thinking that this could be
my last game of the year and we had
maverick Carter here on way back at the
outset of the season saying that LeBron
truly can compartmentalize future
decisions from the actual playing season
all that said what is your best guess
right now based on how everything's
playing out what happens come July 1
well let's not forget the Thunder loss
in the first round and there has been
whispers in conjecture for over a year
now that Paul George and LeBron James
have visions of playing together with
one another and that would be in Los
Angeles so let's consider that and the
fact that the Thunder lost you'd only
have to think that that would encourage
Paul George to end his partnership with
Russell Westbrook so that has to be
considered when we have this
conversation moving forward and then you
look at what the Sixers are doing and if
they're falling flat on their face
against the Boston Celtics that you can
read that one of two ways it could be
that well if LeBron went to play with
them it wouldn't be like him watching on
to a team that was already already made
for a championship he would look like he
was actually the unifying force to get
them to the next level versus had they
say beaten the Cavs or gotten to the NBA
Finals had the Cavs lost earlier in the
playoffs it would have looked the same
way did with Kevin Durant joining the
Golden State Warriors where it was like
cherry-picking a championship those are
facts get looking but then you all set
to just look at what he's doing with
Cleveland you know let's what if just
totally what if now the Golden State
Warriors are juggernaut and I'm not
trying to put any shade or throw any
premature dirt on their grave but if
somehow LeBron with this group wins the
championship in Cleveland what he leaves
I really don't think so and and it's
probably the most validation you'll ever
receive from any championship because
there is no true superstar beside him
and perhaps that you know the best way
for LeBron to feel like his greatness is
appreciated so III think it's too early
to tell I guess is my long-winded answer
but certainly this can only go to help
Cleveland's chances of keeping him I
would assume well and then just one last
thing that this whole what if I mean I
know that the Knicks have been treating
LeBron like that that guy that that
teenager who's mean to the girl he
really wants to take to the prom they
did just hire Dave David phys Dale
and we all know that phys Dale has Miami
ties with LeBron is there any chance on
this green earth that that might
actually resonate with LeBron when he is
looking at option yeah I like to think
that I've gotten to know abroad pretty
well but Dwyane Wade obviously knows him
far better than I do and when we need
publicly laughed in the face of the
billboards that were around msg right
Bryan to recruit LeBron so neck saying
this is ridiculous you're wasting your
time you're wasting your money
I think this nails a great coach on his
own right with - any ties to potentially
luring LeBron I think it's much the same
way the Clippers hiring Jerry West they
hope that by some outside chance that
LeBron could potentially be swayed or
have some sort of iota of interest in
their franchises based on having someone
in their payroll that he completely
trusts and admires and respects and
that's a good strategy just to maybe get
yourself a season table but I don't
believe the Knicks have a realistic
chance nor do I believe the Clippers
have realistic chance to foster so
you're saying there's a chance
take care of Dave love the chat let's
check back in and also yeah just quick
note on Mark Jones we have to say he's
doing that fantastic all with his
brother and attended Paul Jones there's
a progress for the Raptors pretty cool
night for Mark okay sounds good Dave
appreciate you you were just that you're
just you're just Chum full a nugget here
man
get almost like Denver thanks Dave
appreciate it but that's Dave McMenamin
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience